New York Fashion Week when my favorite
thinks is in full-swing now Annie T's
Rachel Smith is on top of the world in
Manhattan right you can see it all from
there huh yeah Brooke the view up here
is spectacular and also on and off the
runway where gigi hadid slayed in every
outfit but she did get upstaged at one
show by her boyfriend Tyler see Gigi
wearing metallics and a wide brim Fedora
was sitting front row versus Bella at
the tummy at sandia show the supermodel
didn't go public with her Bachelorette
boyfriend
oh but Tyler made sure camera saw him
proudly posing outside another
fashionista to hit New York Fashion Week
Priyanka Chopra Jonas I love playing oh
yeah getting dressed I love clothes but
thank God I have amazing stylists but we
caught up with her in Toronto this
weekend where she told us she's ready
for kids with hubby Nick you said that
both homes and babies are on your to-do
list how many homes how many babies
babies as many as God would give us and
the same thing with homes the best thing
that happened on the Internet in the
last month was you photoshopping
yourself that photo I think I was gonna
do to myself I was sick that day a home
which is why I couldn't go to the VMAs
one day one and like just being his face
I felt like I was like I felt like I let
him down at that point because it
doesn't matter if I wasn't there or not
I'm their nanny sure makes it look like
I was Priyanka was at the film festival
for the premiere of her new movie the
sky is pink she stars in and produces
the Hindi language film this is your
first official credit as Priyanka Chopra
Jonas what does it feel like to see that
on the right yeah are you news doing
about that clearly not
[Music]